so leute mir wurde ein kurzer clip im discord empfohlen es geht um ost und
westdeutschland unterschiede und ich habe ja schon ein paar mal erklärt für mich
ist das eine besonders gutes beispiel um rassisten zu debunken
Banken, denn bei Ost-West-Deutschland geht es um Migrationsartefakte, die man messen kann 30 Jahre später und man kann sie nicht mit Genetik erklären, sondern mit Kapitalismus und Wohlstands-, also Vermögenswerten und der Verteilung von Vermögenswerten.
Und ich habe ja hier auch mein Ost-Deutschland-Tattoo und immer wenn mich neue Leute kennenlernen und das Fischi finden, ganz zu Recht, fragen sie mich.
Fragen Sie mich und dann erkläre ich Ihnen das genau so.
Für mich ist Ostdeutschland ja nicht mal ein Nationalstaat, sondern es ist eine Migrationserfahrung.
Und es gibt sogar eine dazugehörige Kultur.
Und alles was so damit einhergeht.
Und wir gucken uns jetzt mal diesen Clip hier an vom Science Slam.
Ich bin schon, ich hab schon Bock jetzt.
Eine ganze Region wird wie durch Zauberhand unsichtbar gemacht, doch die dadurch nicht
verschwundenen Menschen versuchen sich ihren Weg zurück in die Sichtbarkeit zu bahnen.
Was jetzt klingt wie ein Blockbuster, ist es auch.
Nämlich ein Ost-Blockbuster.
Die Titelrolle David Hasselhoff, die Titelmusik die Scorpions und gemeinsam haben sie eine
ganze Region verzaubert und die DDR war verschwunden.
Wir bekamen nicht nur Begrüßungsgeld, sondern auch Helmut Kohl als
kohl als kanzler und blühende landschaften moment einmal irgendwie sehe ich da ja gar
keine blühenden landschaften jama aus sie mögen da manche vielleicht sagen ob es da was zu jammern
gibt werden wir uns jetzt gemeinsam einmal anschauen warum interessiere ich mich überhaupt
dafür nun ich komme aus neuropin das ist wie man sieht im tiefsten osten und bin in der nacht mitten
im naturschutzgebiet ich sage immer naturschutzgebiet nur weil die menschendichte
dichte da oben ist so gering dass es quasi ein naturschutzgebiet ist also brandenburg und auch
mac pom da oben das ist so leer wenn der zeit aufgewachsen und als geograf beschäftige ich
mich mit räumen und dann habe ich gedacht nämlich diese raum doch einfach mal mit an
die uni potsdam und wie es der zufall wird an der uni potsdam hat da die 30
jahre einheitsfeier stattgefunden und da wurden einige beiträge veröffentlicht und
Und ein Begriff kam da ganz oft drin vor, nämlich Critical Westdeutschness.
Was soll das sein, fragen sich jetzt manche vielleicht in dem Publikum.
Ich habe mich das auch gefragt, denn...
Das ist wirklich schön.
Also ich bin ja keiner von den Geisteswissenschaftlern, aber ich habe natürlich auch mitbekommen,
es gibt diese Critical Race Theorie und sozusagen immer diese Idee von, kannst du deine eigene Perspektive und deine eigene Bias...
eine Bias irgendwie relativieren, während
du versuchst, etwas zu sagen.
Du kommst natürlich nie drum rum.
Es gibt keinen absoluten Bezugspunkt, aber
es ist wichtig, diese Critical
Aspekte immer drin zu haben,
damit man nicht die offensichtlichen
Fallstricke runter
mitnimmt. Und Critical
Westdeutschness, das klingt
wirklich, das klingt gut so.
Das gefällt mir richtig gut. Ich merke
das ja auch ständig, wenn
ständig, wenn ich von den
Wessis rede, dass
viele von euch, die hier Morph gucken,
sich da irgendwie getriggert fühlen
und ich finde das ganz
korrekt so. Ihr dürft euch ruhig
getriggert fühlen, ihr dürft nämlich darüber nachdenken,
was ich damit eigentlich meine.
Denn nochmal,
ich bin ja links gelesen eigentlich.
Was meine ich also damit?
Möchte ich eine Ortgruppe konstruieren und
möchte ich Leute diskriminieren?
diskriminieren oder möchte ich vielleicht auf etwas anderes damit hinweisen?
Dieser Begriff wurde nie in irgendwelchen Beiträgen definiert und das habe ich als
Forschungsdrücke identifiziert und wir werden uns das gemeinsam mal anschauen,
was sich hinter diesem Begriff verstecken könnte. Also ab zur Uni Potsdam und wir
werden jetzt die Frage beantworten, was ist Critical Westdeutschnitz und werden
dabei die Frage auch beantworten, was ist eigentlich ein Jägerschnitzel? Denn...
Denn wenn ich forsche, dann sitze ich ganz, ganz viel am Computer, ich lese Texte, ich werte Grafiken aus und irgendwann habe ich einfach keine Lust mehr.
Ich kriege graue Haare von dem ganzen Lesen und von den Daten, was ich da so sehe und dann brauche ich einfach mal eine Pause.
Und dann bin ich mit meiner Forschungsgruppe in die Mensa gegangen und an dem Tag gab es Jägerschnitzel.
Nun, eine Preisfrage. Wer von euch weiß denn, was Jägerschnitzel ist?
Weiß denn, was ein Jägerschnitzel ist? Mal bitte melden.
Ohne Scheiß, ne?
Also bei uns in der Mensa gab es so viele Fälle von Leuten, die bei uns in die Arbeitsgruppe dazugekommen sind.
Oder Studenten, wenn ich bei den Studenten rumgehangen habe.
Und natürlich die Wessis, sie waren wirklich verwirrt.
Und das ist ja auch klar, dass sie darüber verwirrt sind, weil das ist halt eine Überladung des Begriffs Jägerschnitzel.
Aber da, ja.
Wir werden es jetzt...
Ja, da sehe ich ganz viele Arme nach oben gehen. In meiner Forschungsgruppe waren alle aus Potsdam, außer eine Person, die kam aus Bonn.
Sie dachte auch, sie wisse, was ein Jägerschnitzel ist. Und dann kam das da.
Richtig.
Das ist etwas komplett anderes.
Mit der guten Zuckersoße dazu.
Anderes. Damit hat niemand gerechnet. Und ich frage jetzt nochmal, wer hätte dieses Essen jetzt erwartet?
Oh.
Oh, es sind mehr Arme oben, als ich dachte.
Mein Trick ist ja immer in der Mensa gewesen, einen Glasdarm bei Olek dabei haben und nachwürzen.
Aber doch einige und deutlich weniger.
Genau, und das ist nicht verwunderlich.
Wenn wir jetzt mal Google zum Beispiel fragen, was denn Jägerschnitzel ist, dann werden uns diese Bilder vorgeschlagen.
Natürlich, natürlich werden diese Bilder vorgeschlagen.
In den Daten kommen...
kommen die Milieus ja nicht vor, die unter Jägerschnitzel was anderes verstehen.
...pilz, Rahmsoße mit Spätzle oder mit Pommes.
Wenn wir jetzt eine künstliche Intelligenz fragen, dann kommt das gleiche Ergebnis raus.
Das, was Google uns gesagt hat, sagt ChatGPT auch.
Da war aber was anderes bei uns in der Mensa.
Da gibt es wohl eine Data Bias, was?
...also nochmal nach.
Hey, ChatGPT.
Hey ChatGPT, was ist denn jetzt ein ostdeutsches Jägerschnitzel?
Und ChatGPT sagt, es ist einfach ganz genau das Gleiche, es ist einfach nur ein bisschen schärfer.
Das ist schön. Das ist genau die Form von Interpolieren in unbekannten Datensätzen, wie ich es mir vorstelle.
Es weiß irgendwie, wenn man nach Osten geht, dann wird alles knoblauchiger und dann wird alles irgendwie schärfer.
Alles wird irgendwie fleischiger.
Deswegen ist ja klar, dass ein ostdeutscher Sederknetzel einfach nur schärfer ist.
Ich denke mir dann natürlich, ja wir Ostis sind nun mal einfach richtig scharf,
aber das ist halt falsch und das habe ich dann ChatGPT auch gesagt, nö das stimmt nicht.
Und ChatGPT hat dann gesagt, ach sorry, ich habe irgendwie nicht genügend
Informationen um die Frage richtig zu beantworten. Und das ist spannend,
denn warum hat ChatGPT nicht genügend Informationen um diese Frage zu beantworten?
Es geht um Macht und diese Machtstrukturen sind seit der Wiedervereinigung in Deutschland
eben westdeutsch dominiert.
Und hier ist schon das erste Problem.
Und ich denke, das ist auch wirklich das große Missverständnis, was viele Menschen, die
nicht Geisteswissenschaftler sind, mit Geisteswissenschaftlern haben.
Selbst normale Menschen von der Straße wünschen sich eigentlich erstmal eine schöne Zeit.
eine schöne Definition für die Begriffe.
Denn wenn man das nicht tut,
dann kann man einen Geisteswissenschaftler
nicht von einem esoterischen Schwurbler
unterscheiden.
Und eigentlich würde ich sagen, es wäre viel
zweckmäßiger, ich meine,
ich habe ja einen Begriff von Macht.
Deswegen passt das für mich auch.
Auch wenn ich weiß schon,
dass mein Machtbegriff garantiert nicht
sein Machtbegriff ist. Denn ich weiß gar nicht,
wie die das konkret...
konkret in den Geisteswissenschaften definieren. Es gibt ja viele Machtdefinitionen dort.
Haben wir ja auch bei Eva von Redeker gehört.
Der Punkt ist, es wäre viel besser, von Vermögen zu sprechen.
Viel besser.
Dadurch haben wir eine westdeutsche Macht und eine westdeutsche Norm.
Und die sorgt dafür, wissenschaftlich ausgedrückt, westdeutsche Macht plus Jägerschnitzel ist das da.
Das ist die gesamtdeutsche Norm.
normen das da ist die normabweichung und das hat die uni potsdam dann auch das müssen wir offenbar
also norm und normabweichung das sind jetzt offensichtlich wirklich die termini die man in
diesen in dieser also das ist die methodologie von dieser wissenschaftsform dort die mit der
jetzt hier reingeht ich gehe mal davon aus vielen die dort anwesend sind haben das mit den kritikers
studies schon
die ist schon gefressen und wissen deswegen wie die wie man das benutzt und normabweichung scheint
fachterminus zu sein wir wissen was damit gemeint ist jetzt noch irgendwann festgestellt und hat
dann die bezeichnung einfach geändert das heißt es nicht mehr jägerschnitzel sondern panierte
jagdwurst mit pasta und tomatensoße und das fand der gemeine ost natürlich gar nicht lustig und
die uni potsdam der wasser egal das heißt jetzt einfach so und das ist eine sehr spannend
eine sehr spannende Frage, denn warum ist das so? Jetzt geht es hier nicht nur um Sägerschnitzel,
sondern auch um die Wurst. Ist die ostdeutsche Herkunft tatsächlich eine Normabweichung?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Es ist eine Normabweichung, auch im Sinne von, wenn man jetzt einfach drüber
bügelt und Mittelwerte bildet. Eine Frage habe ich mir gestellt und da springen wir doch gleich
einfach mal rein. Ist Deutschland westdeutsch dominiert?
Ein paar Beispiele habe ich mitgebracht. Und zwar gibt es etwa 19 Prozent Ostdeutsche in Deutschland. Wenn wir uns jetzt aber die Verteilung auf die Führungsposition ansehen, sieht das in der Wirtschaft mit 4,7 Prozent, Wissenschaft 1,5, Justiz 2 und Medien 6,9.
Richtig. Und diese Form von Überrepräsentation beziehungsweise Unterrepräsentation würden normale Rassisten im Fall von Messerkriminalität.
Messerkriminalität immer auf Genetik bzw. das, was sie kulturelle Unterschiede sind, runterbrechen.
Weil sie einfach auf Korrelation und Kausalität, auf diesen alten Trugschluss reinfallen und das gleichsetzen.
Das kann man super erklären, wenn man versteht, wie ökonomische Ungleichheit funktioniert und was sie erzeugt.
Was sie alles so für Fallstricke hat und was...
hat und was da für ein Rattenschwanz an
Resultaten rausfolgt.
Und deswegen ist das mit der Vermögensungleichheit so
ein großes Ding. Ich denke, da wird er
jetzt auch gleich noch drauf eingehen. Aber wir sehen halt,
okay, ein Fünftel
aller BRD-Leute sind
Ostdeutsch gelesen, aber
es gibt eine Unterrepräsentation in allen anderen Dingen.
Man könnte ja daraus
Schluss folgern, Moment mal, wir leben ja in einer Leistungsgesellschaft,
jeder kann es schaffen, wenn man sich nur anstrengt.
Ostdeutsche
Ostdeutsche strengen sich nicht genug an.
Und genau die gleiche Argumentation haben Rassisten bei allen anderen Sachen ja auch.
Und nochmal, das kann man hier nicht machen, weil wir alle Biodeutsche sind.
Das kann man also nicht ernst nehmen, den rassistischen Take.
Trotzdem müssten ja Leute, die so gerne sich über Migration unterhalten, das erklären können.
Und das können sie nicht, weil sie unfähig sind zu verstehen, wie Wirtschaft funktioniert.
Weil sie keine Ahnung von Kapitalismus haben.
Militär sogar 0 Prozent. Deutlich darunter aus.
Ein weiteres Beispiel. 35 Jahre Einheit.
Aus diesem Jahr das offizielle Pressefoto vom Bundespräsidenten und der Bundestagspräsidentin.
Kunst, Kultur, demokratischer Austausch, all das gab es in Saarbrücken.
Was es jedoch nicht gab, waren auf dem offiziellen Pressefotos Ossis.
Das sind alles Westdeutsche. Wir haben da sogar einen tollen Talk.
tollen Talkshow-Moderator mit dabei, aber keine Ossis. Das nennt man Repräsentationslücke. So
etwa hat sich die Feier denn wahrscheinlich für Ostdeutsche angefühlt. 35 Jahre Einheit,
wir waren leider nicht... Genau und ich habe das schon mal erklärt in meinem Video zu den
Bauernprotesten damals. Es ist eine unangenehme Position.
zu behaupten, ich fühle mich diskriminiert und ich fühle mich ausgeschlossen,
das ist eine Position der Schwäche.
Das passt nicht so gut in die patriarchale Logik,
in der die wichtigste Metrik, die es zu optimieren gilt, ja die Erhabenheit ist.
Und das ist genau der Grund, warum auch Ostdeutsche,
auch die Jamao-Ossis, wirklich ungern nur...
gern nur als letztes Mittel
dazu greifen, sich selbst
als eine diskriminierte
Minderheit zu
identifizieren und aus dieser Rolle zu sprechen.
Sie möchten
ja viel lieber
in diesen Double-Bind des Nationalstaates
drin sein von wegen, wir sind doch hier alle
Deutsche. Können wir das jetzt mal?
Sie wollen immer noch nach 30 Jahren
diese Wiedervereinigungs-Story einfach glauben
wollen. Das ist Tindereffekt.
Tinder-Effekt übrigens.
Ich möchte ganz dringend jetzt dazugehören.
Und das ist das, was hier ausgebeutet wird eigentlich.
Das ist die männliche Schwachstelle.
Das ist die fragile
Männlichkeit. Das ist der Grund,
warum das funktioniert. Warum man nach wie vor
Leute so voneinander trennen kann.
Weil es einfach unangenehm ist,
erstmal zuzugeben, dass man
sich hier in einer
...
in einer Lage befindet, in der man der Schwache ist.
Nicht eingeladen. Also, ist Deutschland westdeutsch dominiert? Ja. Hat das Ganze denn jetzt Auswirkungen?
Da fehlt was. Genau, hat das Ganze denn Auswirkungen auf die Ossis? Weil man könnte ja einfach mehr arbeiten,
dann würde man auch in Führungspositionen landen. Schauen wir uns das Ganze mal an.
mal an in den Führungspositionen, wenn man Deutsche arbeiten, dann sehen wir, dass man
50 Stunden mehr im Monat arbeitet im Osten. Das sieht man dann ganz sicher auch im Lohn.
Ja, das sieht man auch im Lohn.
Ach was, und hätte man gedacht, dass das schon wieder mit dem Machtkontext zu tun hat,
weil das kann man sozusagen all diese Aspekte, die mit Machtkontext erklärbar sind, die
man in der...
innerhalb der VWL und der BWL-Logik
nicht integrieren kann,
da kann man das nicht beschreiben.
Es ist so herrlich.
Ich hatte letztens erst wieder,
wirklich ein paar Tage her, gerade nochmal
dieses Gespräch darüber, dass nach der Wende
viele Leute
aus dem Ostblock und Ostdeutsche,
die irgendwo angestellt waren,
zum Beispiel bei neuen Wessi-Chefs, auch im Westen
hinmigriert sind und dort gearbeitet haben
in der Industrie.
in der Industrie oder im Bau feststellen mussten, dass die Wessis wirklich schlechter arbeiten.
Schlechtere Arbeitsbedingungen, schlechtere Arbeitssicherheit, die Leute fuschen die ganze Zeit am Bau.
Für einen Ossi war das nicht zu ertragen.
Viele Leute sind da wirklich, also gerade in dieser Wendezeit, komplett krachen gegangen an dieser Vorstellung,
die nämlich lautete, es kommen privilegierte Westdeutsche mit Deutungshoheit, erzählen den Ossis, sie können nicht arbeiten.
können nicht arbeiten, sie sind zu faul, sie sind zu scheiße,
ihre Wirtschaft hat nicht funktioniert, ihr System war scheiße,
weil Ostdeutsche sind einfach schlechtere
Menschen. Und dann aber diesen Kontrast
im Double-Bein zu bemerken, dass das überhaupt
genau überhaupt nicht stimmt.
Die verweichlichte, kasualisierte
Coca-Cola-Zivilisation von da drüben
hat viel mehr
Schwachstellen, kann sich aber aufgrund
ihrer Macht, aufgrund des Machtgefälles
die erhabene Position
erlauben.
Die konstruieren und dichten sie sich einfach hinzu, weil sie in einer Machtposition sind. Und das ermöglicht es. Und ich habe ja schon tausendmal erklärt, der Trick von Herrschaft ist, dass sie einfach behauptet, das Problem zu lösen, indem sie, wenn sie nachguckt bei der Messung, alle dazu zwingt, sich so zu verhalten, als wäre das Problem jetzt gelöst. Und weil es eine Machtposition ist, geht das. Das Problem wird aber dabei nicht gelöst.
Das ist genau das, was hier auch stattfindet.
Aber das habe ich anders erwartet, denn 50 Stunden mehr Arbeitszeit und 5000 Euro weniger brutto im Jahr ist dann doch eine ganz schön große Diskrepanz.
Hat das Ganze also Auswirkungen auf Ossis? Ja, hat es.
Ich empfehle nochmal das Gespräch mit der SPD-Frau bei Thilo Jung aus Sachsen.
Das hat er damals geführt im Zuge der Wahlen in Sachsen, bevor die Wahlen waren. Da hat er ja in Thüringen und Sachsen viele Politiker eingeladen und mit denen geredet und die Frau ist toll. Das finde ich nochmal raus und verlinke euch das. Das Gespräch ist super. Ich glaube sogar, ich habe darauf reagiert.
Das ist jetzt also Kritik für Westdeutschen. Wir sehen hier eine strukturelle Deprivilegierung der ostdeutschen Herkunft bei einer gleichzeitigen...
privilegierung der westdeutschen herkunft wenn das ganze auf der strukturellen ebene ist kann
man sich das aber auch noch ansehen ist das denn bei privatpersonen oder institutionen ebenfalls
so dazu habe ich mal ein zitat mitgebracht von matthias döpfner vorstandsvorsitzender
von axel springer der hat gesagt aussieht entweder kommunisten oder faschisten dazwischen
tun sie es nicht eklig und das ist toll weil dieser matthias döpfner das war doch der der
der mit Elon Musk schon lange vor, bevor der Twitter-Übernahme darüber gesprochen hat,
wie man jetzt Twitter benutzen kann als rechtspopulistisches pädophilen Erzeugnis.
Er hat ja damals per SMS-Spam schon Elon vollgequatscht, wie er sich das vorstellt.
Elon hat nicht darauf reagiert und so, aber Matthias Düpfner ist eine der ekligsten Personen überhaupt.
Ein absoluter Leiß...
Absoluter Leistungsträger. Erzählt die ganze Zeit wahrscheinlich die Geschichte von seinem Erfolg und so. Dabei ist er ein absolutes Würstchen.
Ein echtes Zitat hat er gesagt und das ist insofern spannend, weil Matthias Döpfner ist eine Privatperson, der arbeitet für einen großen Medienkonzern und prägt damit nicht nur die individuelle Meinung, sondern diese individuellen Meinungen tragen das dann wieder in die Institution. Diese Institution prägen dann die strukturelle Ebene und das ist ein Teufelskreis.
Ja, das fällt mir jetzt auch gerade ein, als ich noch so jung war und TV Total mit Stefan Raab ganz neu war und noch witzig war.
Am Anfang, als es nur, ich denke es war nur montags, da war es ja noch richtig witzig.
Und ich habe das super gerne geguckt, ich weiß nicht wie alt ich da war.
Da war ich super klein noch, also vielleicht 14 oder so.
Oder 13.
Und da ist es mir schon aufgefallen, dass er sich immer über die Ossis lustig gemacht hat.
ich es lustig gemacht habe. Ich habe das damals gar nicht verstanden.
Für mich hat diese
die Mauer in den Köpfen noch nicht
existiert zu dem
Zeitpunkt. Das lag
auch daran, dass ich wirklich nie
in Westdeutschland war und deswegen den
Unterschied gar nicht bemerken konnte,
der da vorherrscht.
Aber im Nachhinein
das ist hängen geblieben. Das habe
ich mir gemerkt. Und woher
kommt das?
Und das ist diese Deutungshoheit, über die er hier schon spricht. Da geben Leute mit einem großen Verteiler, also einem großen Machtkontext, geben ihre Deutungshoheit runter. Und das prägt das Netzwerk.
Aus dem es sehr, sehr schwer ist, wieder auszubrechen. Was ist jetzt also Critical West-Deutschness? Das können wir mit der Frage beantworten. Was ist das Jägerschnitzel? Ein Jägerschnitzel ist nämlich beides.
Wir müssen anerkennen, dass beides richtig ist und deswegen ist es wichtig, eine Frage der Perspektive dort aufzumachen.
Das Bewusstsein dafür, dass es eben diese westdeutsche Macht gibt, das ist Critical Westdeutschness.
Das ist eine Perspektive des Hinterfragens und dieses Hinterfragen ist wichtig.
Wenn wir jetzt nämlich mit Matthias Döpfner reden, sagen, hey, wir haben da was festgestellt, es gibt so eine Deprivilegierung von Ostdeutschen,
dann könnte man es natürlich wie die Fans von Dynamo Dresden machen.
machen. Das wäre jetzt aber nicht so wissenschaftlich, deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob ich das empfehlen würde.
Man könnte sagen, hey Matthias Töpfner, da gibt es so ein Konzept, Critical Westdeutschness, willst du das nicht mal vielleicht anwenden?
Nee, das ist zu vogue. Das ist zu vogue.
Perspektive hinterfragen. Jetzt kommt ein not so fun fact. Der weiß das.
Dem ist es aber egal, weil er und auch Friede Springer sind eine der reichsten Deutschen der Welt und sie wohnen in Potsdam.
Sie haben mehrere Villen in Potsdam. Sie selbst profitieren davon, dass es eben diese Deprivilegierung gibt.
Exakt. Und ich habe das alles schon erklärt. Ich habe so ein extra Video damals gemacht.
Ostdeutschland morphs plant. Das war...
Das war, nachdem ich mir mein Tattoo, was ich euch hier gezeigt habe, das habe ich übrigens selber gemalt.
Das habe ich gemalt mit einem Feinleiner, dann bin ich zum Tätowierer gegangen und so.
Und das habe ich für den Thumbnail verwendet, ne?
Damals, ja, richtig.
Das war alles in diesem Jahr.
Damals.
Genau, und da habe ich ja gerade erklärt...
erklärt was daraus was man daraus schlussfolgern kann wenn man jetzt feststellt okay für 90 prozent
der eigentumstitel gehen an westdeutsche und dass man 30 jahre später immer noch wirtschaftliche
ungleichheit messen kann ist kein wunder weil sich natürlich in wahrheit im kapitalismus nicht
da ist nicht das relevante das genmaterial was ich vorab das gibt es auch aber das ist
nicht relevant das relevante sind die vermögenswerte und ja
Und was soll sich daran ändern in einem Wirtschaftssystem, Pyramidensystem, Machtsystem, das sich genauso konsolidiert?
Das ist ja völlig klar.
Was können wir jetzt also damit tun mit dieser Erkenntnis?
Nun, wir wissen jetzt um diese Perspektive und wir haben jetzt gesehen, Wissen allein reicht nicht, sondern wir müssen proaktiv handeln.
Wir müssen aktiv werden, um diese Strukturen aufzubauen.
Richtig. Und es braucht Reflexion, Anerkennung der eigenen Privilegien. Das ist, denke ich, etwas, an dem grundsätzlich zum Beispiel die ganze Patriarchatsdebatte komplett zerschellt. Weil viele Männer, denen es schlecht geht in ihrem Leben, auch insbesondere viele Ostdeutsche, diese ganzen Aspekte, die zum Beispiel mit wirtschaftlicher Ungleichheit einhergehen, die Gewaltausübungen, die sie in der Welt haben, die sie in der Welt haben, die sie in der Welt haben, die sie in der Welt haben, die sie in der Welt haben, die sie in der Welt haben.
Ausübung, die der permanent stattfindet, über die man nicht sich bewusst ist, weil das Wirtschaftssystem einen subtil in Gewaltsituationen reinbringt.
Weil zum Beispiel Geisteswissenschaften keine ordentliche Gewaltdefinition vorbringen und nicht voranbringen.
Da ist es natürlich besonders schwierig, sich überhaupt der Tatsache bewusst zu werden, dass obwohl man unterdrückt ist, man trotzdem noch einen Male Privilege hat.
Das entspricht überhaupt nicht der bewussten Lebensrealität von weißen Cis-Männern in Ostdeutschland, dass sie, obwohl sie sich schlecht fühlen und sich wie eine Outgroup fühlen und darüber übrigens nicht sprechen können, sie trotzdem noch ein Privileg haben.
Und das sind keine Widersprüche, das sind Dinge, die gleichzeitig stattfinden, denn es ist ein komplexes System und man hat nicht nur eine Identität und man hat nicht nur eine.
nur eine Gauss-Glocken-Verteilung, sondern man
hat viele gleichzeitig ineinander verschachtelt.
Und ja,
das ist ein Ding. Das heißt, man kann
immer diese Muster, die
aus diesen Woken-Ideen rauskommen,
super anwenden auf viele Sachen.
Ich bin nur leider auch
der, also ich kann beobachten, dass diese
Transferleistung super schlecht gehandhabt
wird von Leuten mit Sprachrohren
und Leuten, die irgendwie in den Medien
stattfinden und Leute, die das
nicht tun.
Leute, die das studieren und so. Das reicht mir alles nicht. Und das war ja auch meine ursprüngliche Beobachtung, als ich damals meinen YouTube-Kanal angefangen habe. Ich dachte mir, ja, das ist ja schön und gut, aber könnt ihr mal bitte korrekte Begriffe benutzen? Könnt ihr das mal unmissverständlich klar machen, worum es hier geht?
Tja, und jetzt sind wir 2026 und denke, das ist immer noch nicht, ist noch bei weitem nicht geklärt. Und deswegen habe ich ja jetzt angefangen, immer wenn...
immer wenn ich über das Patriarchat spreche, diese Metapher mit dem Autoverkehr zu bringen,
weil es da sozusagen direkt klar ist, dass auch eine weiblich gelesene Person sich wie ein Macho benehmen kann,
einfach nur deswegen, weil es auf einmal in ihren Entscheidungsräumen stattfindet,
weil man ja, wenn man ein Auto fährt, auf einmal viel größeren physikalischen Hebel hat und Arbeit verrichten kann in der physikalischen Realität,
was vorher körperlich nicht möglich war.
Und auf einmal können die kleinsten, zierlichsten...
zierlichsten liebsten frauen auf einmal die totalen straßenrambos werden und das
liegt nur daran dass es möglich ist thermodynamisch ich freue mich dass ich
hier im westen bin dann kann ich nämlich zu ihnen sprechen vielleicht sind ja
manche von ihnen in irgendwelchen führungspositionen und können dann auch
mal überlegen wie könnte ich in meinem unternehmen das ganze dann abbauen
wir könnten
Wir könnten nämlich, um hier in Düsseldorf mal mit Campino zu reden, einen Prozess sehen des Hinterfragens.
So ist es nicht richtig.
Also ich kenne das nicht, was er da verlinkt, aber ich kann es mir vorstellen, dass Campino genauso drauf ist.
Campino ist so ein richtiges, also für mich ist Campino wirklich ein sehr gutes Beispiel für so einen ekligen Besserwessi.
Also alles, was ich sozusagen in...
in meinem ganzen Leben über die Toten Hosen und Campino aufgesammelt habe an gefährlichen Halbwissen,
macht für mich diesen Eindruck.
Das ist der richtige Campino. So geht das. Hallo, ich bin Campino, ich bin Wessi.
Er hat es verstanden. Er hat seine Perspektive verstanden und möchte das dann nun überarbeiten.
und Anerkennung der Privilegien ist wichtig. Diese Kraft könnte man positiv nutzen.
Es gab doch damals diesen völlig peinlichen, dieses völlig peinliche, ich distanziere mich hier von Antisemitismus,
dabei falle ich einfach nur auf Buzzword-Bingo rein.
Übrigens auch von Geisteswissenschaftlern, die absichtlich die ganze Zeit Antisemitismus mit strukturellem Antisemitismus gleichsetzen,
um zu verwirren und es als...
einfach als buzzword und schmieren kampagne zu verwenden die ganze zeit wie halt üblich in dem
sozialen geflecht und in der macht pyramide in der wir uns nun mal befinden in der die wichtigste
metrik die er haben hat ist kein wunder und die repräsentations lücke schließen wenn man in den
medien aktiv ist nicht ausnutzen wie zum beispiel mit diesem artikel der tatsächlich kommt
kurz nach der Wende veröffentlicht wurde. Angeber Wessi mit Bierflasche erschlagen,
er protzte mit seinem BMW herum und beschimpfte alle Mitarbeiter als doofe Ossis. Ganz Bernau ist
glücklich, dass er tot ist. Kurz danach wurde die Zeitung eingestellt. Ich habe keine Ahnung warum,
hat sich nicht so gut verkauft. Na gut, aber das war meine Vorstellung.
meine Forschung an der Uni Potsdam und ich hoffe, dass ich so ein bisschen Licht in die Forschung
bringen konnte und so den Nebel der Unwissenheit vertreiben konnte, wie jetzt alle ein bisschen
schöner und klarer sehen können. Wir sehen jetzt, Potsdam ist eine sehr, sehr hübsche Stadt, könnte
man ja vielleicht mal hin. Genau, da wo Günther Jauch wohnt und so. Ja und die ganzen Eigentumstitel
alle an Wessis gehen, herrlich.
noch, die mir sehr wichtig ist.
Lassen wir uns nicht spalten, sondern
uns eint deutlich mehr, als uns trennt.
Ossis, Düsseldorf,
scheiß Köln. Ja, herrlich.
Wobei, ich denke, ich mag
Köln eigentlich lieber als Düsseldorf, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Aber warum eigentlich?
Ich denke, ich habe wirklich mehr positive Verbindungen
und Erfahrungen einfach
in meinem
meinem Korrelat,
in meinem Nervensystem eingebaut.
Wenn ich über Köln nachdenke,
geht es mir besser, als wenn ich über Düsseldorf nachdenke.
Aber Fakt ist, in Westdeutschland gibt es überall
0,3 Bier und das kotzt mich an.
Dankeschön.
Okay, ja, das war doch herrlich.
Ich empfehle euch auf jeden Fall eigentlich meine beiden Videos zu diesem Thema.
Ich habe sogar drei.
Ich habe damals eins gemacht, die Unterschiede zwischen Ost- und Westdeutschen,
die ich sozusagen bemerke, kulturell, so auf dieser menschlichen Ebene.
Und dann habe ich zwei Videos zu das Ding mit dem Rassismus.
Und übrigens, wie war das eigentlich mit der Wende?
Was ist da genau passiert?
genau passiert und warum ist die Union
eine korrupte Scheißpartei und hat es komplett reingeschissen,
absichtlich wegen ihrer eigenen Korruption
und Helmut Kohl
und so weiter und so fort.
Reingehauen, YouTube.
Thank you.
We'll be right back.
Übrigens, der Kanal ist wie eine schöne Vorlesung aufgebaut.
Wenn ich unten Videos verlinke, dann...
dann wäre es angebracht, sich die auch reinzuziehen, weil das aufeinander aufbaut.
Bestimmte Begriffe werden definiert, viele Beispiele werden genannt.
Und ja, ich denke mir schon was dabei, weil es sozusagen meinen eigenen Erkenntnisprozess abbildet,
die Reihenfolge, in denen ich die Videos hier hochlade.
Thank you.